SPEAKER: So we're
going to give you
an example of how easy it is to
use the identity of our proxy
to take a typical
corporate enterprise app
and make it available
to your users.
Now the specific app we're
going to use in this case
is as enterprise as it comes.
It's Oracle E-business
Suite running
on Google Cloud Platform.
And as a company,
we want our users
to access this application,
whether they're in the office,
or they're out on the road.
So let's see how simple
that is to do with IAP.
Neil is going to click
the button to turn on IAP.
He's then going to tell us
what domain he wants to publish
that application for.
And now users in that
domain, and only that domain,
can access the application.
So let's test it out.
He's going to flip
over to a browser tab.
Now first thing is, there's
no VPN software installed
on this machine.
We are just navigating
into the URL.
Now first he's going to try
his personal Gmail account,
which has not been authorized
for this application.
And sure enough, he's denied.
Now he's going to try it with
his corporate account, which
has been authorized.
And he gets the username,
he gets the password,
but now he will get
prompted to enter
his second key authentication.
So if you look on the sides--
I think we're going to
project that up in a second.
Well, OK, trust me.
He pushed-- there it is.
He pushed the security key.
I think you know
what that works like.
And now he's taken directly
into the application
without having to have another
additional log in step needed.
Not only is this easier
for the developer,
it's easier for the admin.
And Lord knows, it's
easier for the end user
rather than hassling with
a bunch of VPN software.
And it's more secure
because we're not
trusting anybody who
just happens to come in
through a VPN tunnel.
So that's IAP.